joe biden's presidency is in a state of
full-scale collapse it really is i mean
this is the worst week i have ever seen
a president have maybe it is definitely
up there aside from the bachelory in
afghanistan which was a weeks-long
rolling crisis for the administration it
destroyed biden's credibility this week
has been brutal so joe biden this week
alone received reports of inflation at a
40-year high
joe biden had his vast mandate struck
down by the supreme court
joe biden is running up against a major
border crisis again again
joe biden's approval rating is down at
33 according to quinnipiac
joe biden has decided to swivel away
from all of those things by randomly
shouting about how all americans who
dislike his voting agenda are vicious
racists
and now that's breaking down even his
own parties like you're acting like a
jackass please stop okay so yesterday
joe biden went to the hill he's been
trying to convince senators on the hill
that they ought to get rid of the
filibuster yeah good luck with that joe
manchin and christian cinema have no
interest in getting rid of the
filibuster there's no reason they would
be interested in getting rid of the
filibuster
why the filibuster protects them and
protects probably half a dozen other
democratic senators because those
democratic senators now get to claim
that they're in favor of a bunch of
democratic legislative proposals without
those proposals ever having to be passed
that's a pretty good space to be in the
filibuster allows manchin and cinema to
hide behind the filibuster in order to
not have to vote on very controversial
proposals in their own home state plus
it turns out that the filibuster has
long time been a feature of the senate
it is a good cooling mechanism for the
excesses of congressional passion
okay so joe biden went on down to the
hill yesterday
and it just it went it went horribly
just horribly it started off before he
even went down with jen saki at the
white house saying joe biden thinks that
we need to make changes to the
filibuster and it's super duper
important
any piece of legislation that's ever
passed uh that's hard that's difficult
goes through it goes through some ups
and downs and goes through some
challenges that doesn't mean you give up
that's not what leadership is leadership
is continuing to fight for what's right
continuing to fight to get something
done
that means sometimes it fails we don't
know what will happen next that means
sometimes there are gaps between when
you get to move forward we're going to
have to determine what the next steps
are but in the meantime the president is
going to continue to make calls he's
going to continue to engage with his
colleagues and that's where his focus is
on at this point in time yeah well he
has no power to do that because the
president of the united states is not a
sentient being he's an old man who
shouts at the clouds and calls everybody
who doesn't like his agenda a vicious
bull conor racist even though it was he
who was serving in the senate with
people like george wallace and praising
them at the time okay so
here was joe biden he goes down to the
hill and randomly he starts yelling
about voting this is not going to get
the job done sir
the state legislative bodies continue to
change the law not as to who can vote
but who gets to count the vote
count the vote
it's about election subversion
not just whether or not people get to
vote
who counts the vote
that's what this about that's what makes
this so different than anything else
we've ever done who counts the vote who
counts the vote counter vote counselor
vote counts the
not gonna work dude not gonna work in
fact this worked so poorly that
yesterday kirsten cinema well he was in
this
i mean she just burned him to the ground
so joe biden goes to the senate to try
and convince kirsten cinema and joe
manchin that they should give up on
their own political prospects so that
this old man can pass a voting bill
that
she doesn't even like okay and and so
she gets up on the senate floor and
she's like you know what i'm not doing
that i'm not doing that and you can
shove off sir
while i continue to support these bills
i will not support separate actions that
worsen the underlying disease of
division infecting our country
the debate over the senate's 60 vote
threshold shines a light on our broader
challenges
there's no need for me to restate my
long-standing support for the 60-vote
threshold to pass legislation
there's no need for me to restate its
role protecting our country from wild
reversals and federal policy so that is
kirsten cinema just taking joe biden
breaking her back like bane with batman
in dark knight rises i mean it's just
that is a um
that is a bad sight for joe biden and by
the way joe biden knows it he went to
these meetings and then as he was
leaving he got very very agitated
because his his medication had run out
i hope we can get this done the honest
to god answer is i don't know whether we
can get this done as long as i have a
breath in me
as long as i'm in the white house as
long as i'm engaged at all i'm going to
be fighting to change the way these
legislatures have moved
as long as i was pretty dark sir as long
as i brought over my call
joe manchin then put out a statement in
solidarity with cinema
just add insult to injury for the bite
administration quote
throughout the last decade or more
there's been broad bipartisan support
for protecting the filibuster including
current and former members of the senate
just four years ago 61 senators 33 of
whom were democrats sent a letter to
senators chuck schumer and mitch
mcconnell warning them of the dangers of
eliminating the filibuster that letter
presented a united front committed to
preserve the ability of members to
engage in extended debate when bills are
on the floor while some of them have
changed their position i have not
respect is a two-way street i respect
that they have changed i would hope they
would respect that i have not while many
try to ignore this history they do so
without fully understanding the
long-term institutional and democratic
damage this will do to the senate and
our nation allowing one party to exert
complete control in the senate with only
a simple majority will only pour fuel
onto the fire of political whiplash and
dysfunction that is tearing this nation
apart this is joe manchin's statement
he says for those who believe
bipartisanship is impossible we proved
them wrong ending the filibuster would
be the easy way out i can't support such
a perilous course for this nation when
elected leaders are sent to washington
to unite our country by putting politics
and party aside so joe biden reduced to
a sniveling whining shell of a sniveling
whining man so that's that's that's been
a very very very
bad week for joe biden by the way the
democrats are still relying on the
filibuster
and so you think that because they're in
control of the senate they don't use the
filibuster wrong so yesterday there was
a majority bill there's a support for a
bill 55 members of the senate supported
it
they would have blocked sanctions that
they would have reimposed sanctions on
companies that did business with the
russian pipeline nordstrom 2.
that legislation was called the
protecting europe's energy security
implementation act it received a floor
vote after republican texas senator ted
cruz who had proposed it agreed to
release several administration
nominations he had blocked over the
issue
and um then the senate democrats blocked
it
using wait for it wait for it wait for
the filibuster
so while they are declaring it a racist
hallmark of jim crow they're literally
using the filibuster to save joe biden's
pro nord stream 2 position
absolutely incredible
and this presidency is a mess this party
is a mess and so joe biden has been
reduced to just
saying random things and hoping
something sticks so yesterday he did an
address in which he talked about oh
macron and
again he's got no power he's got no
ability to do anything at this point
he's a lame duck one year into his
presidency it's really amazing and so
now he's just going to let all of his
authoritarian id run free he says you
know what i would love i would love for
social media and for the media to stop
their misinformation nothing like the
president of the united states
attempting to use the power of the
federal government to cuddle the media
into place that's good i thought this is
a threat to journalism when trump did it
when biden does it it's good
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop please also he he also he
says wearing a mask is a patriotic duty
um he doesn't specify which kind of mask
here he is
as i've said in the last two years
please wear a mask
if you're in a you know i think it's
part of your patriotic duty it's not
that comfortable
it's a pain in the neck
but
i've taken every action i can as
president to require people to wear
masks in federal buildings and on
airplanes and trains because they're
internet they cross state lines and it's
been so wildly effective sir i mean i
mean it's not like we have any omicron
cases at all because because of those
measures
really great job i mean in new jersey
new york you know places where everybody
agrees with you i've noticed that um
everyone's getting infected with donald
cron
by the way michael osterholm who used to
advise biden
he's like this is an amazing statement
so he says cloth masks don't work
against domicron but then he goes
further he says the thing you are not
allowed to say the kind of thing that
gets you banned from youtube if you are
a member of the non-liberal party if
you're not a leftist and you say this
then you're treated like joe rogan
you're an abomination unto the lord
here's michael osterholm saying
something about cloth masks that has
been perfectly obvious for nyon two
years but you weren't supposed to say it
here he is
the science was there we published work
back as early as april of 2020
saying that in fact that this virus was
transmitted by an aerosol that kind of
perfume like floating in the room and
that we needed to have that very high
level of respiratory protection you need
these very tight face fitting masts that
also have breathable and what i mean by
that is its fit and its filtration and
the way you get fit is like a swim
goggle you can't have it leak but if
it's going to be that tight then you
have to have a material that allows the
air to move through cloth doesn't do
that
wait what now
hold up so he just said one second you
need a tight fit
which would be can 95 or 95 you need
that but anything that's loosely fit
or of a or of a material like cloth
doesn't work
and he says we had data of this in
april of 2020. if you said this for a
year and a half on the internet you were
banned
you're banned they would throw you off
facebook for this they would throw you
off youtube for this michael osterholm
can say it he was an advisor to joe
biden he's liars he's unbelievable liars
okay so it's all falling apart for them
the good news is they have waiting in
the wings one of the most talented
politicians of this or any other
generation kamala harris who is just
she's just an inspiring figure deeply
inspiring figure so kamala harris did an
interview
on nbc news it's one of the great
interviews of all time
uh kamala harris is perennially the
third grader whose dog ate her homework
forever and always
she has two responses to questions to
laugh hysterically like a lunatic
or to try and soldier her way through
them like michael scott being asked to
describe the french revolution here is
here is kamala harris being asked a very
simple question and man this answer this
is an all-time great answer right here
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
she's the most talented politician of
our generation
and by the way every two days there's a
piece in the mainstream media about why
she needs to recapitulate her image
there's another one in the washington
post like it's almost every two days
saying why her her comms team is failing
her because the dictator can never fail
the dictator can only be failed maybe
she just sucks at this that's one of the
great selena kyle v lines i have ever
heard from a politician in real life
quote it is time there's a direct quote
it is time for us to do what we have
been doing and that time
is every day
okay i'm trying to get a handle on what
that means
today right now it's the time for us to
do what we've already been doing and
that time
to do what we've already been doing is
every day and so the past and present
and future all merge
it's like it's like a flat circle
well
yeah play it again play i i need that i
need the experience of that level of
genius again i need it i need it i
require it this could be your next
president of the united states folks
because joe biden needed a black woman
for veep six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time every day it's time
to agree to agree that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
my favorite time is that it is time for
us to do what we have been doing and
that time of is every day
every day
is that time
it's like a
haiku
for a person who has no brain function
it's that is that is
fantastic that is just fantastic
i guess that the the goal here is that
our leadership class should be actively
unable to form english sentences about
coherent policy
we're almost there guys if we just work
a little harder we'll get there
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content